Razi Congrats you got engaged that is
beautiful
tell me about this gentleman this is
Kelvin Superbowl champion there he is
that is a very good-looking man he's
good dude I met him he's good dude good
yeah it's my sister yeah so I gave him
the game face oh yeah what do you do
show me the game face when you met him
that's the Tracy grump face yes so it's
just curious it begs a question how did
you meet I met I have a makeup artist
who was sick and tired of me being
single and she was like you're not gonna
meet him at home I was like well if he
knocks on the door and I'm out in the
streets with you I just missed my shot
yeah so she she like orchestrated this
whole party and she invited all the
eligible bachelors in Chicago and like
you're my pimp something got a blind
date girl I was like it can go really
bad and I will embarrass you so you need
to start showing me some pictures of
these guys are invited yeah and so she
kept showing me kelvins picture and
that's the first picture she showed me
and when I look I zoomed into his eyes
and I was like he just touched me here
and I was like something about his eyes
are just very gentle oh that's nice and
so I think and playing the whole time
and then finally the night of the party
I'm like in the party and everything I'm
like okay where is he so when he comes
over to this section I swear it's like
the room disappeared a spotlight hit him
and it was like
so you both knew right away Tracy I
don't want to leave you out of this
equation you just had your three year
anniversary isn't that right how's it
going I'm happy about it your honor I'd
love again and you know my wife is
biracial she beautiful my wife she's
biracial so before we have sex
I'll take a knee just to let the whites
I don't know black lives matter
[Applause]
you making her happy
yeah she's very about this thing she can
you sit ins warm want money she gave my
trucks is a job supposed to get hit by
truck talk to Roger yes sir
so you wanna come to the road you need
to get your funky ass off this $50,000
couch and hit the Turnpike and look for
a truck guineas the world dreams so we
talked about it was crazy about it is
that my brother I thought my settlement
I found out my younger brother was
working for Walmart
so they started taking the settlement
money out of his jacket that go over
with him I don't know I said don't say
that me they told you to do that hit me
Yeah right
well you have the right perspective on
this whole brush with that
you know being married to a young girl
like that it puts you at a disadvantage
he's much younger than you
yeah she's 18 my wife is 18 years
younger than me oh so I'll put you at a
disadvantage and if you might say when
you have a beautiful woman like this so
like that and you knew it put your
because you're not going nowhere you
never never gonna leave he's never gonna
leave you oh I told my wife the other
day let me tell you something you keep
treating me the way you treat me one day
you won't wake up numb be sitting right
there
[Applause]
[Laughter]